[موسيقى]
الحمد لله طبعا كان طمانينه يعني يعني
جينا من وضع سيء جدا بس الحمد لله اللي
كنت مقيمه هنا في السودان ولا بتعمل في
السودان كنت شغال في السودان فالح
[موسيقى]
مد لله
اهلا وسهلا
ويلكم
[موسيقى]
ايش المعنى ايش المعاناه والمشاهد اللي
انتم عشتوها في السودان اثناء الاشتباكات
يعني هو الرعب الطياره من فوقك كيف هيك
يعني رعب كان فظيع تقريبا
[موسيقى]
وصلتوا مع السفاره السعوديه هنا
تواصلوا معاهم قالوهم قالولهم نروح على
الميناء البري البحري وبس وجينا والحمد
لله كل شيء
[موسيقى]
السعوديه تعمل على عمليات النقل عبر السفن
البحريه الضخمه او فرقات السعوديه بالفعل
المتوقع خلال الساعات القادمه انتم تكون
هنالك عمليات اجلاء مستمره خلال الساعات
القادمه او يوم غدا كما ذكر صغير السعودي
في الخرطوم يتم استقبال كافه الطلبات
ودراستها
[موسيقى]